welcome back today on Las Vegas now Las
Vegas is teeing up for Shriners Children
the sponsors of this segment I stopped
by for a special tournament that you're
invited to this weekend take a look
so the last time I was with Shriners
Hospital it was on the green at a legion
stadium and now we're here on the green
at TPC Summerlin for the Shriners
children's open the 39th year welcome
back to Vegas Mo thank you so much we're
excited to be here so tell everybody
what Shriners Hospital does if they
don't know sure Shriners children's was
founded over a hundred years ago first
as a response to the U.S polio epidemic
but since then we have specialized in
pediatric specialty treatments for
children around the world and have now
cared for more than 1.5 million children
wow in 39 years of this event in
particular dealer you know what does it
mean to you and what does it do for
Shriners Hospital this is a great event
for us to partner with the PGA Tour
there's obviously the best golf that you
can see right here in Las Vegas up close
but it also brings awareness to our
great Mission as well as an opportunity
to raise funds and to encourage people
to donate
that's a very important part of this
tournament are our national patient
Ambassador so Mel give our girl a grand
entrant yeah we couldn't be more excited
to have Catherine with us this week she
is our national patient ambassador from
our Boston hospital and is with us this
week all right Catherine what has
Shriners done for you and give us your
story
um so about three years ago I was in a
car accident
um it left me unknowingly if I was gonna
have to have an amputated leg what my
future was gonna look like as far as
walking never mind soccer and when I
arrived at Shriners I just immediately
knew that everything was going to be
okay the people there the doctors the
nurses everyone all the staff they just
make you feel so comforted and they
truly changed my life and brought me
back to living my dream so it was
amazing incredible and you mentioned
stalkers so tell everybody what you do
and where you're playing at right now
I'm a sophomore at Northeastern
University I didn't know what position
do you play I play center back nice I
love it okay but you know how else are
the patients involved in the in this
event one of the things that makes the
Shriners children's open so unique is
the way that we integrate patients onto
the course and so this weekend they will
actually be serving a standard bearers
and we have brought in a patient from
every one of our facilities in North
America and each one of them will be
actively participating in the tournament
walking the course alongside the pros
and it's a great way to show all that
our patients can do now who were some of
the golfers that people can check out
here we we have an incredible lineup
this year Patrick can't lay Jordan
Spieth just an amazing array of golfers
and the thing that's really unique about
this tournament is the way that the
course is laid out you really can be up
close and personal and so we just
encourage as many people as possible to
come out see the pros support the
incredible mission of Shriners it's a
beautiful course the weather looks like
it's going to be perfect and it just
it's going to be a great weekend and we
would just love as many Las Vegas
residents to come out and join us come
on
no better cause than this
thank you to Shriners children's for
sponsoring that segment the open goes
through Sunday and at TPC Summerlin so
for more just call
702-873-1010 or visit Shriners hospitals
open.com we'll be right back